what's up youtube yesterday over a
thousand of you guys stayed on for an
hour as we walked down a private event
speech that i gave and i redid the
speech just for instagram live and
youtube for you guys and so we cover in
the video is one the content creation
model that we've used to grow over a
million person audience over the last
six months number one number two is how
to position yourself in your messaging
so you don't sound like a dick number
three the concept behind giving away the
good will and then selling the
implementation because a lot of people
feel like they have to keep their their
best stuff hidden when the reality is
you got to give it all away and then
you'll always get so much more than you
think you will number four was the three
traits of ultra successful people that
i've seen of all the people that i know
who are worth a billion dollars or more
they have these three traits in common
and they're not exactly what i expected
them to be the next one is the best way
to scale a sales team because that was
one of the questions i got the chat and
i was really excited to talk about so i
broke down the entire process of how
we've scaled the next one is discussion
around closing because now we went from
the big team down to like how do i
actually get people to say yes and the
three frameworks that i use to walk
someone across the finish line how i
deal with failure and then finally i
give you a little bit of a sneak peek on
the next book all right so hope you
enjoyed the live from yesterday and i'll
see you on the inside i'll give you guys
you guys want the um
the skinny the scoop on what the
presentation was if you guys can throw
like some hearts or some thumbs up um
okay cool so i'll give you the the kind
of the overarching theme which was
uh you know the first third of it i uh
you know had to bring everyone up to
speed who didn't know you know what our
deal was um but in the last six months
we've grown from like 180 000
person audience across like all channels
to like 1.2 million now um in the last
six months so it's been a lot
of growth and i mean no one's
experienced it more than me and so i'm
very grateful so that's all you guys so
thank you so much i'm really honored um
and so kind of explain that and then the
second portion was kind of like the
tactics which is like what do we
actually do to do that and i'll cover
that in a second um and then the third
part was
my observations on like the things that
worked big picture uh rather than like
the blocking and tackling like hacks and
things like that so let's go into kind
of section two which is the tactics so
there's kind of a five step process that
we've been doing and uh caleb's been
helping me out with this but basically
we we test first and so this works
because i used to email myself i don't
know if you guys are like i am i used to
email myself like brain dump like if i
had an idea on a conversation or someone
and i was like i didn't want to lose it
i would just email to myself and this
never ending thread of like me to me i
don't know if you guys have that um
and then i would go record content i'd
look at that thing and then i would try
and come up with my content ideas um but
what i discovered was i could use
twitter as my brain dump uh and take
basically the same amount of time as i
would to email myself with the contacts
and whatnot but i could just do it on
twitter and then what would happen is
what used to be a private you know
communication became a public thing so i
was able to share something that
otherwise wasn't being utilized and then
the added benefit was twitter and like
tech talk i would say are similar in
that they're very fast testing like you
can post 10 times a day and it doesn't
like hurt your account whereas you know
instagram people are like hey man i've
seen enough of your stuff like one post
a day is fine or whatever and so on
there you can post plenty of times and
then you get to see the engagement
because both of those platforms are very
like viral ready it's so easy to share
and whatnot and so from those we see the
best performing content and then that is
what i then use to create
to basically record videos off of so
tweets turn into videos the threads turn
into long videos the short tweets turn
into shorts and then that becomes from
there we record those things
step three is we
add call to actions to them which is
something that we actually just recently
started doing so you'll probably see it
more on these videos and stuff in the
future um but we just started doing it
to my podcast if you haven't checked
that if you are an audible person or an
audio person uh the game podcast if you
didn't know we have a podcast um
has uh just grew from like 20 000
downloads a month
to
400 000 downloads a month which is like
insane so you guys are awesome i love
you i'm glad that it's providing value
um but the biggest thing that we did to
get the growth was um literally just
saying like hey if you like this like
leave a review and share fred
share a friend share our friend um and
so
so we start so we started doing that and
then that's what everything just blew up
which makes sense because like the book
for example had a ton of virality to it
because there was call to actions
embedded within the book and so we just
took like what we already know works
within business we need to be reminded
more than we need to be taught um and
just applied it to something that i'm
not as familiar with like i don't
consider myself like a content creator
like i you know we do business stuff and
like we try and capture as much as we
can and so um doing that uh
we started interjecting in three places
the beginning the middle and the end and
if it's longer you can do a couple mid
roles um and so what we did to
operationalize that was we took like
what are all the call to actions you
would have right because you want to
always be the same thing because some
people get like banner blindness so it's
like for me it's like you know hey check
out the book it's 99 cents you can go
download it you're like go check it out
it's got five thousand five stars like
people seem to like it uh you know hey
leave a review that would be awesome uh
you know tag me in this uh or send this
to a friend so it'd be a share ask um
hey if i have an event coming up which i
don't but if i had an event coming up or
if i was like hey i'm gonna do a
workshop with like you know five
entrepreneurs over you know a million
bucks a year if i then i would just
point people to something like that um
if you had a lead magnet that would be
one of those things and so you get the
idea like whatever wherever you want to
direct traffic that would be the call to
action but here's the here's the shtick
or here's the thing that the nuance that
made it work is that rather than just
doing one
do like five for each one of them and
then you've got like 30 of these that
you can sprinkle in and then they seem
really organic and because i i'm doing
them really short they're only like you
know five or ten seconds they don't
they're not like these three minute long
ads that everyone wants to kill
themselves and just immediately skip
skip skip skip shift until they get to
the end of the ad right and so it's like
little call to actions that are small
enough that people actually hear them
and different enough that you don't get
like audioblindness
and so that was uh step three
step four was contextualized and so what
i did in the presentation i showed this
image you guys remember the meme that
was like uh dolly parton was that she
started it said like me on facebook me
on tinder me on instagram you guys is
this cool you guys like otherwise i'll
just be ranting on my own okay cool do
you guys want me to do more of this
because caleb is we have a bet i'm i was
like no one's going to show up
and if someone showed up then i would
lose the bet which is probably a very
one-sided bet i should not have taken um
but anyways so dolly parton uh there's
tinder linkedin all that stuff right
so that was the meme and so if you look
and i have this visual
if you look at a lot of my tweets a lot
of them became tick tocks and then from
that short tick tock i have a youtube
shorts version and i have an instagram
version and the thumbnail and the text
are contextual to the platform and so
you guys have probably seen people who
like take a tick tock and then just like
post it the same thing with the tic toc
watermark on instagram or they take the
same tick tock watermark and they put it
on youtube shorts and they have the same
like
caption and whatnot around it and same
thumbnail
i think that people feel that like you
didn't take that extra little bit and
this could be me judging i don't know
i'm just sharing what worked for us um
and so we try to make it contextual to
the platform and i think that's been
helping um and so that's step four so
test on twitter record shorts as short
as long as longs
add the call to actions to drive the
action drive the action drive the
actually looking for it drive the
traffic wherever you want uh four is you
um
contextualizes the platform that you're
distributing on and then step five is to
actually distribute it and this is the
this is the little little lesson that i
learned and so i shared this i think on
my youtube channel but i had a
conversation with cardone i don't know
six months ago and this is actually what
was probably the big impetus
excuse me catalyst for for this
happening for me ramping up everything
we said he said look at your instagram
bro look at my instagram and i was like
okay and he's like volume bro he's like
i'm posting five times more than you are
and he said look at your twitter look at
my twitter look at your youtube look at
my youtube and it was just such a stark
contrast in terms of the amount of
content that he was putting out compared
to me and then it became really obvious
and so what ended up happening is we
went from posting seven times a week
which was three youtube videos a week
which three podcasts a week and one
instagram post that was all i was doing
and we went from seven times a week to
80 times a week across all platforms and
so it was a 10x increase in content but
here's what's interesting we didn't get
a 10x increase in quantity we got a 10x
increase in growth rate so the actual
net result went from 180 000 which had
taken us 12 months to build
to getting to 1.2 million in six months
of building
and so the rate of growth 10x
and so literally the input was
equivalent to the output in terms of the
the equivalence between those things so
right now if you're thinking yourself
man i would love to grow ten times
faster so whatever your growth rate is
on a new platform if you're thinking
about it
i could i will bet you i don't know if
it'll be a dollar to dollar increase or
a one to one increase but i'll bet you
if you do more you won't get less
and so
that's you could take that promising
back um
and so uh
when i started doing that that's when we
saw this explosive growth and the thing
is is i told this other story that
hopefully you guys won't mind me sharing
with you you guys cool just getting like
some of the the nuggets from uh the
event cool okay um
i uh i had a mentor really early on when
i had my gyms that told me to start
putting flyers out right and so i put so
i listened to him and i put flyers out
and i waited a few weeks nothing
happened i went back to lunch with him
and i was like hey we did the flyers
thing um it didn't work uh he was like
what do you mean i was like well i mean
one guy called me but he's because he
said i dinged his car uh it was a
mercedes and i just tried to talk to him
really nicely and get him off the phone
um and uh he's like what was your test
size i was like what do you mean he was
like well how many did you put out oh i
put 300 up it's like 300
well yeah it's like dude i don't even
test for less than 5 000 flyers
i was like oh
well that explains it he's like and then
we do 5000 a day once we have a winner
it's like
oh
and so that wasn't even like 2x or 5x or
10x it was 20x
and that was a per day not in total so
if you did at the end of that month you
would have put up a hundred and fifty
thousand flyers and i put up three
hundred
and so i'm looking at the difference in
results between this really successful
business person to myself and i miss
mistakenly thought that the issue was
the strategy
rather than the execution and so one of
the number one things that i feel like i
get in my dms all the time is like hey
i've been doing the rule of 100 and you
guys don't know what that is it's my
like little stick for if you do 100
primary actions a day to promote your
business or make your products and
services known you will get more
business which means if you do 100 cold
calls you do 100 cold emails you do 100
dms whatever that is you do 100 of that
primary action per day or if it's ad
spend spend 100 a day um
whatever it is or you do 100 a week if
it's actual organic content i promise
you
you will have more business than you
know what to deal with your problem will
not be demand generation it will be
satisfying the demand that you have to
handle
and so the thing is is that people hear
that they hear the rule of 100 and i had
a guy literally message me and said hey
i've been doing the role 100. i just
crossed 100 i started eight weeks ago
i was like
what do you mean you started eight weeks
ago and you crossed a hundred it's like
well i mean i've done a hundred you know
reach outs over the last eight weeks
i was like bro uh so 7 times 8 is 56
times 100 should have been 56 000 reach
outs in that same period of time and
hopefully you're catching the drift here
that it's not these like
2x 3x increases in volume it's typically
multiple orders of magnitude it's not
10x it might be 100x or 300x in the case
of the flyers or 56 000 versus 100 in
that same period of time and the issue
is that most people dramatically
underestimate
how much effort is required to achieve
goals that are dramatically above what
the norm is experiencing and so it's
like right now if you're getting normal
results it's usually because you're
putting out a normal level of output
which is almost non-existent because
everyone's so afraid of someone leaving
a mean comment
the amount of bean comments that i get
is unworldly the amount that it
influences me because i
it is is love um and that's variety
reason to get into uh it's mostly
because i love you guys you guys are
awesome so you guys have you guys bury
those comments and so mosey nation you
guys rock thank you again um
and so that was section two of this
thing you guys want to hear section
three i can give you guys the stick okay
so section three the consolidated
version of this and i'm still like
working on it so this was like the thing
that made this uncomfortable for me
because i think if i were to redo the
entire presentation the entire
presentation would have been
section three altogether
and it just would have started there and
then gone down because everything that i
shared with you although it's incredibly
important
probably lacks the one thing that i
think matters most which is that
most people
are talking about [ __ ] that they have
not done
and the way that they talk about it
makes people hate them
let me explain
so if i said for example
let's say
all right let me just let me try and
paint it differently so let's see that
you're you're on your newsfeed who here
sees people shaking their finger and
telling them what they should do on
their newsfeed all the time right plenty
of
people
now
how how many times have you gotten you
know seen the 18 year old relationship
coach
uh who's on your news feed trying to
sell coaching for relationships right
the dating expert that's 21 years old
right have you guys seen this can i get
like some hearts or some thumbs going if
you guys have seen this right it's
ridiculous why is it ridiculous because
there's an unspoken question that must
always be answered in my opinion which
is why should i listen to you
and so i think the common reason that
people are not experiencing the growth
and the brand and the authority that
they wish to build is because they're
trying they're putting their ladder
against the wrong wall they're trying to
build something that they do not have
the authority to presume and so for
example if you wanted to build a
business brand right if you look at the
biggest influencers in the business
space so you look at andy frasella you
look at garyvee you look at patrick but
david if you're a youtuber you look at
you look at uh you look at ed milette
right you look at these guys
a really important question is how many
of them needed the social media
following they have in order to make the
money they make
none
and so they have the authority to talk
about business because of the [ __ ] they
have already done
and so it's kind of like and i hear this
all the time it's like man my content's
so much better than that guys i can't
believe people you know share that kind
of stuff if elon musk tweets i'm on the
the porcelain throne right now it'll get
500 000 shares and it's not because of
the content it's because of the frame
and the brand that is wrapped around
that message it's because elon said it
that made it important
right and so the idea is it's very
difficult to deliver theoretical
knowledge on business without having the
proof or the evidence to substantiate
the theoretical knowledge you're
claiming to have because it doesn't pass
the litmus test of like why should i
listen to you why should i listen to the
ten thousand dollar a month business
coach
why wouldn't i listen to tom billy
because we were like well i'm making the
same stuff as tom and i'm like yeah you
are i was like except you're missing the
one thing where you build a billion
dollar brand
small thing that you're missing right
where you've got the the stay-at-home
wealth coach right that's talking about
how you should dollar cost average into
the stock market and being like dude i'm
giving way better advice than warren
buffett is and
maybe maybe you're saying the exact same
thing as warren buffett it's not fair
that warren buffett gets all this media
and you don't except for the fact that
he's built a hundred billion dollars in
net worth and made so many people
wealthy through berkshire hathaway like
there's just that that little itty bitty
wrinkle that's missing and so if that
sounds hopeless to you there is good
news
so the point is is that first identify
if you're doing that if you are probably
stop the second thing is that you change
the way you speak all right and so
changing the way you speak comes in
terms of how you talk and what you're
talking about so that what you're
talking about the way to be unfucked
with the ball so that people can't shoot
you down who can't give you hate is by
saying
listen
i don't know
this is just what i did and this is what
worked for me this time
i hope it serves you
versus
this is what you need to do to get what
i have or this is what you need to do in
order to do x it's the difference
between how to
to how i
so you start your message with how i
built
a 13 million dollar a month company not
how you can build a 100 million dollar
company
it's minor but it's huge right it's kind
of the difference it's almost like the
difference of saying like hey you want
to buy my [ __ ] versus hey do you know
anybody wants to buy my stuff it's these
tiny tiny little pivots in language that
that have deep implications behind your
intention of how you're speaking to them
when you say you should or how to you're
presuming a place of authority that you
may not have earned whereas if you're
always coming from the place of like i
had oatmeal for breakfast
right no one's gonna object with you on
that you're like i had oil for breakfast
but if you say
you should have oatmeal for breakfast if
you want to look like me how much more
do you hate me now
a lot and it's just a difference in
language and so the idea is that we
change the way we talk and what we talk
about and so rather than talking about
the general ideas of an industry which
we probably don't have the authority to
presume because we don't have the
experience the depth of experience to
make sure that our assumptions are valid
across the sizes of business because you
may make an assumption and you make a
statement that works for a 10 000 a
month business and then everyone else is
like well
i can think of a hundred ways that's
wrong
and then you look like an idiot but if
you say hey this is how i've gotten to
ten thousand a month i hope this is
helpful for you no one's like [ __ ] that
guy that's not how he got to ten
thousand a month because they don't know
they can't they can't they cannot
challenge your experience and if you
want to make a pivot on that you can say
hey this is what i've been doing with
john and jim and casey and sarah to help
them with their skin care condition to
help them with their home remodel to
help them with their xyz
so i hope it helped you out because this
is the frame we made for them and they
seemed to think it was useful so i just
wanted to share with you guys if you if
you speak from that perspective it's
speaking from experience rather than
theory and most people who are talking
right now are just taking garyvee's
content taking other people's content
diluting it watering it down and then
delivering it from a position of
weakness because you don't have the
brand and you don't have the authority
you don't have the expertise or the
experience real or imaginary to make
these claims
and so i think the heart of the issue is
not i mean sure there's the blocking
attacking of the volume and the
distribution and contextualize the
content all that kind of stuff right
there's all of that and for sure you
have to do the doing it has to gets done
but the heart of it comes down to
talking about things that you have the
authority to speak over and it reminds
me of a speech from morpheus from the
matrix where he stands up and i think
it's in the second or third i can't
remember and he and he stands up and he
says i stand here truthfully unafraid he
said not because of the path that lies
before me but because of the path that
lies behind me because no one can
question the things that you have
already done no one can question the
experience that you've amassed even if
it's this big and the thing is is it's
about it's about
doing the first step and then talking
about what you just did and what you
just learned and then taking the next
step and then talking about what you did
when you just learned now the the
maximized version of that is having
a caleb behind the camera and and miked
up all the time so we can capture that's
gonna we're gonna be making more stuff
for you guys on that because you guys
asked for it and we're building the team
to try and deliver that for you guys um
but that takes time and it costs money
to do that so i get that and so i think
that just doing the doing and then
talking about what you did is one of the
simplest way to document the lessons
learn how you progress and grow over
time and as a total side note if you
like want to check this out if you go on
my podcast which is actually the oldest
platform i've been on by the way
i have like four i mean almost 400
episodes on there you can go back six
years ago and listen to the difference
in terms of like what i was talking
about then and what i'm talking about
now and part of the reason that we
document the stuff the mission the
business for acquisition.com is the
document to share the best practices of
building world-class companies is that
it how
shitty is it that jeff bezos doesn't
have a vlog of him being like day 37 at
amazon you know trying to trying to get
these books shipped out you know had
some shipping issues today but you know
going to get after it tomorrow like how
invaluable would it be if we could look
back at jeffy b's
you know library of content and see him
build one of the biggest companies of
all time same with steve jobs same with
elon musk right and so i was my hope is
that you know we get to a billion and
beyond and i i hope that because i want
to have
the journey documented with the lessons
that i learned along the way and the the
shifts in belief like earlier today i
got asked by somebody who's listened to
all my podcasts they're like hey podcast
86 which by the way is four and a half
years ago they're like you said this
thing
and i was like you know i think i've
shifted my understanding of that and so
i was like there's more nuance to it and
so it's really cool for yourself to
document these things and when you do do
it from that perspective which is to do
it for yourself to do it because you
believe it should be made because you
want to add to the body of knowledge
rather than preach to somebody to do it
not because you want to feature ego
because you want to feed the audience
if you can do it from that perspective
then i think the audience can feel the
intention and so that kind of leads to
what i would consider to be like
probably one of the later points in the
in the presentation which is
the whole concept around giving which is
first off
humans are exceptionally good at
sniffing out intention and i think
that's evolutionary and deeply wired in
us because we have to know when we're
getting double crossed we have to know
and try and be able to guess if
someone's lying to us and so we're
actually very very good like even people
who have like necessarily like lower iqs
or lower processing power still can have
exceptionally good ability at sniffing
out lying and sniffing out in tension
just sniffing out like into ill will
and so because it's evolutionary if you
weren't able to do that you get double
crossed you get your coconut stolen
right and so we have this really innate
very tuned instrument inside of us that
can hear attention in tonality and micro
expressions and so i don't think you can
fake it i think you just have to truly
shift your perspective so that you can
live
in that way authentically which is to
actually believe that if you give to
your audience over a long enough period
of time you will reap higher rewards and
so i want to be clear since day one i've
always been in it to make money
but i think that the vehicle that we use
to make money is a longer game and i got
asked on i think evan carmichael the
only other time i've been on instagram
live was like hey man why are you one of
the good guys who like why haven't you
like sold out or whatever and i was like
well first off i want to be clear we're
equating selling with bad which i would
never do um number one number two is
that i'm absolutely a capitalist and
long-term greedy it's just that i think
that me working with companies thinking
about my unique skills of getting
someone from three to thirty three to
fifty million
is more valuable for me to work with a
handful of people just everyone else
stuff for free so that they can get to
the level that i can then work with them
right rather than trying to build a
massive infrastructure around you know
helping tens of thousands of people try
and consume the content when i can just
give it to them for free right which
leads to another big point that i have
around this at least a belief that i
have which is
give away the secrets sell the
implementation and so a lot of people
have info behind walls and that's fine
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that but the real value add for the
service is the implementation the
accountability the troubleshooting and
the perspective from which to solve the
problem so i'll give you an example so
let's say you want to get better at
sales right so i could make tons of
sales content if i wanted to and then
people be like wow this guy's really
good at sales because i give away all
the secrets right but they might consume
it and be a little bit better but they
would be even better if they had a coach
who's like listening to their calls and
seeing like see right here you paused
and then she lost trust with you or hey
see how here you should have made this
into a question rather than making a
command and if you did that you could
have sold more off your back foot than
your front foot right or like dude you
missed report in the first two seconds
because you said this instead of this
right and then the whole call has been
off since then or she said this
objection early on and then you didn't
catch it so she just detonated it in the
sale and you should have confronted that
earlier right and so if you if you don't
have the perspective from which to get
better at the skill because you already
only have your baseline skill set
because you can't it's very difficult to
self-appraise that is where having
coaches mentors people who are better at
teaching the skill comes into play
and so
you give away the secrets to prove you
are good because here's the here's the
flip side people were like what if what
if i what if i give away all these
secrets and everyone consumes them right
what if you give away a whole bunch of
[ __ ] and everyone consumes it
which one do you think you're gonna make
more money on
people make their purchasing decisions
based on the value they've already
received not the value that they're
going to receive
like it's a really big point that took
me way too long to learn
one of the strongest persuasive powers
in existence is reciprocity if people
get something they feel almost like it's
like sick to their stomach they have to
give something back right it's just most
people are like it's not everyone there
are some crazies out there for most
humans because all of our civilization
has been based on this concept of
reciprocity right
and so you can force reciprocity in your
direction by just jamming so much good
will and so much value down someone's
throat that they just feel like they
have to vomit back on you in terms of
value because they're so full on value
they're like getting drunk with the
value that you're providing for them and
so when you do that it results in a sale
and i'll tell you one of the lessons
that i learned later this has just at
least been true for me
is that
the end of your value ladder of the
ascensions that you can create for a
customer is predicated on the last thing
that you provided that was in excess of
value from what you charged
so if you think about the first thing
you do is your content is free it's
worth more than what you're giving
because you're giving away everything
and so then they purchase the first
thing and if that first thing let's say
is a thousand dollars but it makes them
ten thousand dollars they're like well
[ __ ] yeah what else you got you're like
well i got a ten thousand dollar thing
and they're like i'm in
and then they make 100 and they're like
dude what else you got you're like i got
a hundred thousand dollar thing and this
is the part where people [ __ ] up is that
the hundred thousand dollar thing they
get a hundred thousand dollars of value
and then what they have done is now they
have now completely
squeezed the price to valley discrepancy
and what they have is not a a raving
customer but a satisfied customer and
then that is where the customer
relationship ends and so the idea of
being able to consistently and always
have more demand
than you can fulfill
is predicated or is based on the ability
to always provide not just a little bit
more but significantly more than you are
charging for and so there's two ways of
doing that one is you can decrease your
price to the point where it's basically
nothing and so if you give anything over
nothing it seems more which is what is
kind of the premise around free content
but the thing is is that free content
does have a cost it's just not monetary
it's time and attention how many people
do you know who make content and they
get no [ __ ] engagement on it it might
be you you might be that person why do
you think that is
because the price of free is still not
worth it
real [ __ ] right
and so the idea is like if you are in
that situation you make this free
content you say content doesn't work and
so you keep putting out shittier and
shittier content because you keep saying
that it doesn't work i think if you can
flip the script and say hey
what if i made all of the stuff that i
have that's free more valuable than what
my competitors are currently charging
for
what if i make my free stuff better than
their paid stuff
and if you really truly try and do that
not just like say that but live that
look at think about all the deliverables
that happen think about all the the
checklist and the and the cheat sheets
and the visuals and the videos and the
in-depth trainings that you would
provide if you were to try and get your
course and what if you just gave that
away
what happens if someone makes 100 a
month using your free stuff
they [ __ ] want to give you money to
buy more from you
reciprocity and so as long as the next
thing that you have
can provide even more value because
probably if you were able to help them
make a hundred thousand dollars off of
your free stuff you probably have enough
expertise to help them make a million
dollars
right and so that's the idea here is
like
how can we provide so much value and
access that they want to continue to buy
from us over and over and over again
right that's the that's the stick
and so when we're chunking back out to
this right i said in the beginning we've
got our our five method right we can
test
we test the right stuff then we uh
record the stuff
then we add call to actions to the stuff
so we direct the traffic where we want
we contextualize it to platforms and
then we increase our volume that's the
tactics the heart behind it is that we
think
i will only talk about the things that i
know of that no one can question i will
talk about how i did something not how
to do something i'll talk about what my
clients did not what you should do
and i will base that from a perspective
of i will try and give away as much as
humanly possible so much so that it
makes me sick to my stomach and i'm very
afraid of the amount of value that i'm
giving
because i know that based on reciprocity
if i give more value out there i will
get more in return because you can give
at scale with content so think about
this
if it costs you the same amount to
provide value in a video to one person
as it does to provide value to a million
people who watch a video just think
about it conceptually
it costs you no more effort to do that
but the beautiful thing with technology
is that there's still only one of you to
receive from everything that you did on
a multiple with leverage at scale
like i don't know if you can see this
visual but you do one level of effort
one input
and technology amplifies it to everyone
but then it all has to come back into
one which is you and so you could this
is how you can amass significant wealth
like this is how it works so caleb asked
me the other day he's like dude people
say leverage all the time he's like what
does leverage even mean
this is what leverage means leverage
means the ratio between inputs to
outputs in a system
and so if the input that we have is time
or money if we have something that has
lots of leverage it means we get a huge
multiplier effect if i put one unit in i
get 10 units out i get 100 units out
that is a high leverage activity or
system
and so the
aggregation of wealth for people who
have money
is a function
of
understanding time because wealth is
based on the fundamenta fundamental unit
of money money is a foundational unit of
time why because you can trade them back
and forth everybody here can trade their
time for money it's a it's an even
exchange system and so here's what's
interesting everyone can trade time for
money
but you can trade some time for more
money right and so what we're doing when
we gain leverage is we're looking at and
this is the people who are the
wealthiest is that they have control
over their time so that when they do
give it they get the most
out of it right and so the game of
business to aggregate wealth is to play
with higher and higher and higher
amounts of leverage over the one thing
that we all have the same amount of
which is time
and so mastering that is the key to
becoming wealthy so you you master your
time in order to master your money and
so there's two components to mastering
time you have mastery of time which
comes down to the micro which is the day
to day the speed of activity and i can
tell you right now if you talk to
somebody
you say hey we should do this thing
right and then boom they've got this
organized they've already done two or
three messages and then like it's
getting done tomorrow i guarantee you
that that person is going to be more
wealthy because they have a micro
mastery of their time
right
on the map actually i'm gonna explain
that even a little bit further so think
about this from from an organizational
perspective imagine that the default
time period that you use to get
something done
is let's say a week let's say that's
just the unspoken default that's the
cultural default of like hey we need to
start this project hey can you get this
this thing to me they said cool i'll get
you by end of week right end of week
that's d500 is okay with that right
but let's say because you want to become
a master of wealth and you understand
that time is huge is one of the is one
of the biggest components of wealth you
then say no guys the new default is end
of day
for all activities unless stated
otherwise that becomes the new norm and
so let's say that this project that we
had originally has several back and
forth interactions they give something
to you it takes a week you get them
something back it takes a week to take a
week take a week take weeks the whole
thing takes seven weeks right
now imagine it was end of day
the same output happens in one seventh
of the time because we both get a dumb
end of day next day two things happen
next day two things happen next day two
things happen and then boom the
project's done what took two months
takes somebody else four days
and when you multiply that effect over a
year over a decade that is when you see
the outsized returns in wealth and money
because of mastery on the micro of time
the second component of time is the
macro perspective of time which is
are all of the activities acting in
alignment with my overall goal and do i
believe that they can compound on one
another are they directionally aligned
over a decade over three decades so that
i can have a compounding effect leverage
in action
over a longer period of time so that my
input is is far less or my output far
outweighs the input that i did
because i let time work as an asset
rather than a liability most people's
plans when you add time get worse
what you want to do is play games where
if you wait you win
and so those are the games that we want
to set up and those are the games that
the people who are truly wealthy
understand and so i can tell you having
dealt with people who make significantly
more money than me their mastery of the
micro of understanding how speed moves
things forward because on a macro scale
of getting things done day day day day
day day rather than week week week week
means that at the end of the year they
have 40 times the output and people are
like that's not fair
said life was supposed to be
right and so
this micro
kind of exchange that happens there gets
enhanced and magnified and people get
upset about it but the thing is is you
can either decry the system and hate on
it
or you can accept it for what it is and
just choose to play the game and win
the way you want to if that's what you
want and so
as the micro and then from the macro
perspective like i was saying earlier is
that
the biggest shift that i see in people
who are wealthy is that they talk in
decades not days and i can tell you
based on the time period that someone
talks in when they talk about their
plans how wealthy they are
or
to be fair how wealthy they will be
and so if you have truly realistic plans
that you're like this is what's gonna
take me about 10 years if you hear
someone say that i can tell you that
they're going to be successful and if
you can shift your perspective to that
where you actually start planning and
like okay
it would be unreasonable that if i did
this for 10 straight years that i
wouldn't be significantly wealthier than
i am today
so that's what i'm gonna do and then
having the singularity of mine to not
get distracted
and so there's three things
they did a research study on this i
found this interesting hopefully it will
too actually you guys digging this
because i was this you guys good digging
um
and if you want throw some questions in
there uh because i'll wrap up my little
my little my little diatribe here um
there's three things that they found
that made people who were ultra
successful and ultra successful i i wish
i had the definition for what they
define as ultra successful but we'll
just leave it at that
they said they have a superiority
complex and
they think that they are in some way
better than other people and deserve
more than others number one
number two
they have massive insecurity and fear of
failure they they never think that they
will measure up or be good enough
interesting paradox
and then number three
is
they have impulse control
and so think about this from a bigger
picture perspective
they have the superiority conflict so
they believe that they can accomplish
these amazing things like how like some
people if you tell them your goals
they'll say how dare you think that way
how dare you believe that you could
accomplish something like that and so it
takes a little bit of delusion in order
to think i'm gonna make an iphone
whatever the [ __ ] that is i'm gonna put
a computer in everyone's hand in the
world
i'm gonna do that right most people
think it's hubris and the only thing
that separates
genius and insanity is what happens is
outcome right and so they have this this
vision of where they want to go and they
believe they can do big stuff number one
number two they have this fuel that they
push away from from always feeling
they'll never be good enough right
that's what drives them towards this
this outcome
and the number three and this is the big
one this is the one that everyone messes
up
is they have the impulse control to stay
focused on it and not let shiny objects
distract them even though there's
another opportunity comes up two years
in
they're like
no
if i keep doing what i'm doing and i
follow the plan that i set i will be it
would be unreasonable that i do not
achieve the goal that i have could this
help maybe but even if i don't do that i
will still get there and i would rather
take the get rich for sure than get rich
quick way every day
and most people this is my finding at
least
if you were to sit down with someone and
say here's a contract you sign here and
you're going to live on 30 000 a year
for the next five years
but at the end of that five years you'll
be able to make a million dollars a year
most people
would sign that contract
but they don't live like they would sign
that contract
and so if you can and the reason that
that contract works is because it delays
the gratification
it it separates the i'm going to have
the cookie today from i want to have a
six-pack for life
right it's the i will suffer for this
long period of time i will make the
hundred dials i will make the hundred
pieces of content a week i will spend
100 a day on advertising and sacrifice
my lifestyle in order to learn not to
get rich but to learn the skills that
will make me rich eventually
and i know that if i accumulate these
skills because i'm dedicated to that and
i'm willing to sacrifice more than other
people to achieve my dreams and i'm
gonna i'm gonna put a pit on this real
quick because i think this is real
how many of you to save humanity would
sacrifice your life
like throw a like a like or a thumbs up
or something like that like how many of
you guys attack like would give your
life for maybe even your country right a
lot of people would do that a lot of our
military do we appreciate that you serve
like how many people would do that or
save your family
pause
why is it
that that is more important than your
dreams
because i was asked in an interview
a few days ago
why were you willing to sacrifice so
much
and i feel like the better question is
why are people not willing to sacrifice
anything
it's like if you're willing to sacrifice
your life give the ultimate price
for a country or for
whatever
why would you not give at least that
much to realize the potential that you
believe you have
and so
that's for me why the sacrifices never
felt like sacrifices they felt like
trade-offs and for me they were
trade-offs they were prices i was
willing to pay
and so it's like
if there was a pair of shoes that i
wanted it was 500 and i bought them and
someone's like don't you feel guilty
about spending 500 i would say no
that was the price and i was willing to
pay because i wanted the shoes
period
and so if there's a price tag that we
can ascribe to our dreams or to the
potential that we believe that we have
which is what we want to pay down as
regret in the future for not having it
if you read the price tag and it says
you know football with the boys
dodgeball during the week you know
drinking a couple of nights some a
little bit groggy if that's the price
tag
is that a price i'm willing to pay
and i think if you are
you'll get significantly closer to what
you're trying to do and so that was uh
that was the the general gist of the uh
of the chat that i had not chat it was a
presentation at the best do you guys
like that was that cool i didn't get a
little bit of recap and this is not the
normal style it's the first q a
q a ever you can thank caleb
hopefully i won the bet and he's he's
not told me that anyone actually is live
so i could just be ranting at the uh
iphone
but if you guys have cues or a's about
any of that stuff
um let me know in the chat and uh caleb
will read them out to me and then uh
we'll uh
rock and roll from there a common
question we got is what would be your
number one tip for building a sales team
okay number two for building a sales
team is hire a very good sales manager
that's a that's a very serious answer
hire somebody who's already built a
sales team that's the the real answer
the second and much harder answer is
learn to sell yourself learn to sell the
product um
train the next person to manage the
product
read books on sales management which
comes down to communication cadence and
managing uh a training process a
recruiting process and then a management
process so there's three big things that
have to happen in the sales team you
have to recruit the right talent which
by the way let me save you a lot of time
it comes down to much more of the
picking than it does to the training
right because it's much easier to take
somebody's naturally graded baseball and
get them better than get somebody who
has zero eye hand coordination and
trying to get them to become a pro
you can it'll take you three times as
much time to get someone from a 205 then
it takes someone to take a seven to a
nine all right so number one is being
able to spot your town and recruit them
onto your team
number two is the training component
which is you need to get as specialized
as humanly possible and here's the key
point that i think most people mess up
in their sales training they focus on
the product not the prospect
so the whole time they're trying to
educate their team on the bells and the
whistles and the things and the
differentiators between them in the
competition well most of the time the
other people have on the phone don't
even know the competition number one
number two they don't even understand
the features because they don't
understand the problem and so what we
should be talking about is why are you
here what problem are we solving
and then we should have very deep
context to what are the common issues
that the prospect is suffering from
because at the end of the day the more
accurately you can depict the pain
someone is experiencing the more you can
enter the internal conversation and
dialogue that's happening in their mind
the more they will believe whatever you
have next and so if i can perfectly
describe what your situation is right
now just imagine that i was able to
describe your life and the things that
you suffer from right now perfectly
if i said if i just described it all to
you be like geez it's like this guy like
knows everything i'd be like and that's
why i think you're a good fit for the
program i wouldn't even need to tell you
about the program because you'd be like
geez i mean if he understands my problem
that well
then i'm sure the solution will work and
so that's why also from a flexibility
standpoint if you train your sales team
on the prospect you can swap products
out as as needed
but the prospect will probably not
change and so when we're training so
first we recruit the right people we
pick right right so the uh the the
championships are one in the draft right
not not in the offseason
number two is that we train around the
prospect on the product
and number three
is that we manage around the values of
the team in the headspace and we manage
towards one key thing which is
conviction because if you have somebody
who's been recruited well and they've
been trained on the pains of the
prospect the only reason someone's not
going to be able to sell is because they
lack conviction something happened they
got a text they got a call somebody's
complaining about something and all of a
sudden their conviction drops and you
can see this because if someone was hot
and then goes cold it's not because they
don't know how to sell because they were
hot they already know how to sell it's
because they stop feeling motivated to
close and so when someone gives them the
initial objection they shrink away
because they don't believe that they're
really helping the person
and so then they don't want to push any
further because i can tell you let me
say this imagine
imagine you went back in time
and you were going to talk to your old
self from 10 years ago right and you
wanted to say hey
there's this thing called bitcoin you
should get into it and sell it on this
day all right i know it means nothing
right now this is the day that you're
going to sell it on but here's the thing
if you went back in time you had to not
be you you had to just come in another
body so to you you're a perfect stranger
but you're talking to yourself
think about how
you would sell that person
that is what somebody with conviction
sounds like and every everything that
they come up with to be like
let me let me let's let's dive into this
more you're suffering from this let's
let's let's pull these pieces apart no
like i think we do need to make a
decision because every day like you
start breaking it down the way you would
talk would change because of the level
you were convicted and a key point on
conviction is not that it's binary this
is a false thing that people say it's
not do you believe in the product or not
believe the product it's to what extent
do you believe in the product how deeply
you believe in product
i ask you a question have you ever have
you ever
talked to somebody about something and
they had some cockamania something that
was insane right
but they talked about it with so much
conviction that you started to question
your own beliefs because i convicted
they were
that is the power of conviction over any
tactic in sales
and that's again the thing that i was
talking about earlier with the intention
right people can smell out intention and
so if you have the genuine deep desire
to help the prospect and you genuinely
believe that this product or program or
service is going to change their life
then selling gets easy the hard part is
doing that which is why most of sales
get fixed by fixing those things and not
necessarily having some super insane
program for training you pick the right
people you teach them about your
prospects but the things that they're
really struggling with and you teach
them to have a question-based
conversation which is why are you here
what have you struggled with in the past
why didn't that work
okay now that i've understood those
things i think you might be a good fit
for our program can i tell you about it
yes x y and z does that make sense cool
we can move forward it doesn't have to
be complicated right like that simple
sales script is what we taught thousands
and thousands of gym owners and they
closed millions and millions and
hundreds of millions of dollars in sales
using that because the more complexity
you add to the system the easier it is
to break and so for me i've always
taught off question-based frameworks
because when you just ask questions it
always gives you a home base so if
someone goes out you know they're all
the way out in outer space you've got to
bring them back a question can always
bring someone right back on point you're
like thank you so much for sharing that
boom next question right you can walk
them down towards the sale
so when scaling a sales team best option
is to hire an experienced sales manager
done this before if you can't do that
then you need to learn how to do the
sale yourself recruit someone who has
the already ideally track record work
ethic intelligence candor to sell and
ideally in a selling environment those
similar years if you're doing high
volume transactional sales then you want
somebody's done high volume
transactional sales if you're doing you
know enterprise level sales then you
want somebody who's done a long sale
cycle who's probably more of a farmer
than a hunter it's different personality
stuff you got to make sure that you
match those so you start recruiting then
you create a question-based framework
just for the script and the rest of the
time you're educating them on the
prospect not the product and then
finally from a management perspective if
someone is dipping all of the effort
goes towards raising their conviction
educating them on all of the things that
we're doing to help our our prospects
succeed giving them the testimonials
having live clients hop on and talk
about how their life has changed saying
hey dan remember how you sold johnny two
weeks ago well here's johnny and his
life's totally different johnny left
like can you share your experience all
of a sudden dan now feels like the next
guy he gets on the phone with is just
like johnny
and that is how you can fix someone's
sales without even having to get into
the nitty-gritty and sure every morning
you do your huddle you know deal with
the overcomes people are struggling with
make sure we drill stuff do the
role-playing you obviously have to do
that that's the blocking attack that
we're selling but if you want to build a
world-class sales team it comes down to
the culture of conviction
so that answered that question
what are uh three books that you would
recommend people read i've only read one
so
uh
i honest real talk i think it would be
much better so i have this youtube video
that says i was once weak uh it's on my
channel i genuinely think it's the best
i mean i i think it's it's one of the
best presentations i've ever given and
it's literally just about closing and i
think if you just it's 90 minutes of
just straight closes and if you can
understand that and it and it shows you
an ethical approach to closing which is
about giving the power to the prospect
because the reason that people don't buy
isn't because they don't want to buy
it's because they're afraid to make a
mistake and so what they do is they give
their power away and so there's three
ways to give their power away from the
outside end they give it to their
circumstances first so that's time
that's money or that's some particular
aspect of the program they don't like so
time wise
i'm not going to get into all the
overcomers because it could go forever
but time wise we all know that it's not
about time it's about priorities right
how can how can somebody become a
self-made billionaire you know what i
mean and like we all have the same
amount of time so that's and i can give
you the actual scripting around that but
just watch the video to explain it the
second for circumstances is money which
is not about money it's not about
resources about resourcefulness so
what's the difference between somebody
who's broke and a billionaire who lost
everything and then builds it back again
well both people have ground zero at one
point but the difference is that one
person is resourceful the other person
isn't and so it's not about resources
about resourcefulness so right now if
you are broke
every south paid billionaire who was
broke you're in the exact same position
as them so which means it's not an
excuse which means if let's say tomorrow
you needed a 50 000 surgery how would
you come up with the money
how would you come up with it
and this is an easy question for
everybody because this is this is what i
think really drives it home that sounds
like a hypothetical
who here is on the live right now
motivation love you guys by the way you
guys digging this is this cool
rocking okay
who here has had an unexpected bill come
up
maybe something like maybe your car
breaks down maybe you have a tax bill
for my business owners any huge tax
bills all of a sudden they came up what
about uh what about a payroll tax for
example that you forgot that you weren't
paying anybody
or you have a major water breakage
right
you're still here you still have a phone
you're still on instagram right now so
you obviously survived
and here's what's interesting
we are willing to become resourceful
when we feed someone else
but not ourselves
so when you had to pay your landlord and
pay rent you figured out a way when you
had to pay the tax bill the irs you
figured out a way when you had to pay
the bill for your car breaking down you
figured out a way but for some reason
when it comes to investing in yourself
you're not
and so that's because people blame the
circumstances rather than themselves and
so we peel this back right so we're
having this conversation with the
prospect and so the three things
circumstances so time money fit so fit
is like uh i'll give you a simple
example they say uh there's broccoli on
this meal plan i hate broccoli i don't
eat broccoli right
and the easiest overcome there is just
you gotta change the change
there's a lot of stuff that you can
unpeel there but you just simply say
like i mean so many people are like hey
well i currently eat this for breakfast
can i just like have that on the meal
plan i'm like well that breakfast got
you that body so probably not
got to change the change that's the
fundamental truth there so
those are the three that happen in
circumstances the next level that people
will cast [ __ ] to pass their power
to is other people so to say i can't do
this because my spouse can't do it with
my kids i can't do it because my
employees i can't do it because uh big
bird doesn't matter right the thing is
they will say i can't make the decision
because i'm relying on someone else to
make this decision
and
there's a fundamental flaw in this and
the big flaw is this is that if we fast
forward the clock two years
who are you going to blame for the life
that you have
yourself or the person that you're
giving all the power to of course them
and that's not fair the relationship
that you're going to have and so what
you're doing is you're asking for
permission when you should be asking for
support
real talk and so the thing is is
obviously there's sub ones underneath of
that which is like hey do they you know
they approve your current situation you
know if they say you know no they don't
approve it they're not happy that i'm
you know feeling this way it's like cool
then why would they be against something
they already don't approve of cool if
the rules were reversed what do you
think would happen would you help would
you be okay with them doing something to
help themselves well why do you think it
would be different for them right like
you can these are all like the simple
like mini mini overcomes but the big one
is that you're asking for permission
instead of support
right because you really have to
logically play this out and so once you
get someone to say you know what you're
right like i need to take control of
this cool now we're talking to somebody
who's in charge all right which gives
you the last circle and the last circle
is avoidance is that now when someone
says i need to think about it or i'm not
sure
at least you're talking to somebody
who's in charge
which is amazing and so if you're a
sales person and someone gives you a
circumstance thing you might be two
levels that you have to still keep
overcoming to get to the gold now if
someone says a spouse thing you might
have to overcome that and then still
have to overcome an avoidance thing but
if you can think about peeling back the
onion from the outside in then what
we're doing is we're not selling we're
giving this person the power to make a
decision and the objective of the sale
i'm going to say this i want to just
[ __ ] inscribe this in everyone's
hearts is that the point of the sale is
not to get them to buy the point of the
sales to get them to decide
and so if you guys don't know the
definition of of decide comes from latin
which is to cadare which means to
literally cut off and so the question
you ask the prospect is that's what this
word means
and so the question is which future are
we cutting off today
are we cutting off the future that is
more aligned with the dreams that you're
trying to accomplish are we cutting off
the past that you're trying to step out
of
which which path are we cutting off
today
right we need to make a decision all
right and so now at this point when
you're in avoidance you're talking to
somebody in power and so we have to do
is get them to confront that is the
theme of this one so we have to get them
to confront the decision which most of
the time just means they don't even know
how to make a decision and so i like to
use the frame of past present future
and so
the past is saying is usually overcoming
past worries that they've had past
mistakes they've had so simple examples
like hey i did something like this in
the past it didn't work i'm afraid of
the same thing happening again right i
call this the burn you twice which is
hey
do you ever date anybody in middle
school
yes are you married to them no did you
swear off the entire gender because you
had a bad experience no well because if
you did then you'd be allowing that bad
experience to burn you twice once when
you paid for it and didn't have it work
out and second when it prevented you
from meeting the love of your life
and so we can't take that one experience
and let it burn you a second time so
that's not a good reason is it and then
it's like well do you think that
eventually you're going to do this do
this thing right this is me getting in
the future but like the more fluid you
get with this the better you'll get but
getting into futures like do you think
you're going to like be struggling with
this forever well no okay well do you
think you're going to eventually have to
do this sure or if you're going to do it
eventually might as well do it now
right and so
there's the past which is about you know
burning twice the other thing that you
can pull from the past is like do you
think the reason we're having the
conversation right now is because you've
had trouble deciding
do you think you've gotten this point
multiple times in the past you haven't
been able to pull the trigger and that's
why we're here today
how much is not making this decision
cost you up to this point
is it more than the cost of this
i don't think this is a fast decision
because you've been making this decision
the last five years today's just the
first day we're taking action on it
right so we can keep like you can keep
going through that's all past right
presidents they admit all that stuff and
then now you're boom you're in the
present with the person and you have
somebody who's in power who who shakes
off all the [ __ ] they've had in the past
you're like great do you know what it
takes to make the decision and usually
they'll say no
and you're like great there's three
things that you need to figure out one
is do you think the product is going to
help you solve the problem that you have
the way that you want it to be solved
yes or no
yes
great do you want to work with me and or
us yes or no
right
do you know someone or have access the
amount of money to get started yes or no
if they say yes then you're like great
we just made the decision what card you
want to use
you have to help them make the decision
and if they're still there they're like
you know what if you're anything like me
you're probably afraid of making a
mistake does that sound fair
what are you most afraid of having
happen
right what are you afraid of
i think it's one of the most powerful
questions in negotiations and sales
because you're what are you afraid of
having happen let's play it out right
and this gets into another close call
let's consider the options right but
say like let's consider the options like
worst case scenario right i go to vegas
i take your credit card number i send it
to a nigerian prince he maxes everything
out and you don't get the result you
want right right okay do you think
that's gonna happen no okay well at
least we're not there right okay so
we're we're getting closer to gold
we're getting closer all right what's
the what's the real worst case
well
i just don't want to fail again okay
that's beautiful
what would make you feel like you're not
going to fail again what would you need
to say
and then this as soon as they start
answering this question you've got them
it doesn't matter because the thing is
they're going to say i wouldn't see this
in this and you're like we already have
that you shouldn't know about it because
i didn't talk about features earlier
because that's not important
it's important is how you feel because
at the end of the day like you just have
to trust that our intention because you
have to trust the person more than the
paper
right to walk them through the process
and so even then i think in the future i
wouldn't get into it but you get the
idea here so big picture what we're
talking is this is this valuable for
everybody is this joe because i can talk
about sales all day
can i get some hearts and stuff okay
cool caleb's talking because i i still
this could be the ultimate prank because
i still can't see the phone and so right
now in my mind i'm talking to myself
this entire time
so
so big picture you have these big
concentric circles from the outside
people who start with the lightest
[ __ ] because it's the easiest thing
to cast your power to i don't have time
i'm too busy i don't have the money uh
you know this doesn't sound like a
perfect fit for me those are the easy
things right and we go one one step
closer to that which is then
is other people right and then we say
hey
it's about asking for support on
permission right we explain how in the
future they're going to blame them for
for everything and that's not fair to
them it's not fair the relation if you
want to value the relationship long term
this is what you have to do you have to
own the decision cool boom now we're in
the present and we go past present
future past we get them to give up all
of the reasons that they've failed
before as not something that's getting
influenced today you teach them how to
make a decision and then you confront
their concerns that they might have and
you can talk around them right and the
easiest one and i'm still working on
creating a framework around this but
i'll share it with you and you can share
with your sales teams if you like it
then i'm trying to figure out like a
skeleton key overcome and so there's two
that have a high degree like you can use
them in a ton of scenarios and i've used
them all time so you can use them for
your sales team number one is called the
reason close and the reason close is
whatever reason they give you you say
that's the perfect reason you should do
this so if they're like dude i don't
have the money to start the program like
that's the exact reason you need to do
this program if they're like i don't
have the time to start the program like
that's because like this is the very
reason you do the program
right it doesn't matter what the thing
is you just say that's the very reason
you need to do this right so it's called
the reason close
the second close is something i'm
working on called like the hypothetical
close so you guys have probably heard of
like the unicorn clothes and the one to
ten clothes those are all closes that
have similar themes around them and if
you're not familiar with that is you
know the one to ten closes you know if
this were a one and you hated it uh i
wanna skip from one and that would be
alex you suck i hate you your breath
smells and i never wanna see you again
and ten being like this is uh this is a
program that i want to get started today
right uh where are you at right and
here's the key it doesn't matter what
number that they say let's say they say
six you say okay cool well what would
you what would it take to make you
attend
and they literally give you the thing
that they said to get a yes and then you
can also flip it and say why aren't you
a one and then they start selling you on
why it's good
right and so that's the one to ten
clothes the unicorn clothes is similar
which is just like hey if this were some
amazing uniform program would you do it
they say yes
now if they say no then you say cool
then i don't think we need to talk about
this stuff affiliated with something
else going on and then you can start
attacking the actual uh the objection
which is like you don't trust me like
let's talk about that right
but
this is what i'm working on for skeleton
t so i gave you the the reason clothes
the other one is the skeleton key and so
which is the hypothetical clothes and so
this is what i'm working on so i'm so
figuring this out but if i said the hype
whatever thing they say so let's say
it's time let's say it's money doesn't
matter and i say cool so time's the
issue right okay so uh if time weren't
the issue would you do it
you guys see where this got right
and then they're like well yeah you're
like cool
and then we dig in and say then what
would it look like to have time
and then they have to generate the
responses and we're like oh cool well
that's not going to take that much time
the first thing we're going to do is
replace all these activities which
you're spending you're spending all your
time on not getting results and replace
with things that are
great
solve the problem and so what happens
with the hypothetical close you
basically take their object their
obstacle and you say cool if that
obstacle didn't exist would you do it
because the thing is is once they say
yes you got a hypothetical yes so all we
have to do is match the conditions of
the hypothetical yes in the real world
and then we close the deal
and so those are two of the strongest
like multi-use closes that work at any
point in this whole kind of equation um
that i like a lot that i've used like a
fair amount and so you can use those
with your team but just like hey
sweet you guys have any more uh any more
questions because i know that was that
was really valuable um like it was a
good question
uh one of the questions is uh this was
from a while back but how do you deal
with failure
uh i mean
i don't want this to sound like
dismissive as an answer but like
most people just have the wrong i don't
say wrong like
i just don't
i don't i don't feel bad about failure
because i don't see failure as bad
and so
this this chunks up into a larger
conversation which is that most people
ascribe labels positive or negative
labels to situations
and so this again gets into my worldview
which i'm not going to get into but
we have a meaning maker in our in our
heads and so our entire lives when we're
children we're going around and we're
just asking adults what does that mean
what does that mean what does that mean
and we just take
whatever they tell us as the meaning for
things right and the thing is we don't
remember every single person who told us
what every single thing meant we just
took it as fact and then later on in our
lives when we have enough other meanings
that we can triangulate positions on we
can say that doesn't make sense i don't
know if that's true and the problem that
most of us have is that we deem failure
and we were told that failure meant that
we were a failure
and that's false
because failure is a necessary part is a
requisite for success and so here's the
thing this is something i can promise
you
if you are not failing right now you are
not going to succeed
it is a requisite it's a requirement for
success and so how do i feel not bad
about failure well if i told you that
there was seven steps to success let's
just say and you were on step four would
you feel bad
of course no
but let's just say that step four is
failing
all it is is just unpacking the label
that we've ascribed to this thing and
just looking at it for what it really is
which means i made an attempt and i
learned something and then i will
incorporate that new learning to take
one step closer to what i what my
desired outcome is
and like all of life is a learning
process not to get like two whatever but
like that's what it is and so the idea
is that we see failure is bad that's the
problem that's all it is so that's it
genuinely and i i hope it doesn't come
unrelatable off unrelatable but like
it just doesn't bother me
everyone's asking about the your next
book
i
it will be done
when it is worthy of your attention
and so right now i have
right now i've i've written five
versions end to end of the leads book
and i'll just tell you guys what the
problem is the problem is that the
offers book was such a defined
thing that i was fixing that i could
create a manual to solve it and everyone
could immediately read it and then 10x
the prices do all these things and
improve how much money they're making
when it comes to leads
it's actually a significant more complex
topic
and so it's not just like
how do i do cold calling how do i do
cold emailing how do i do cold messenger
how do i do how do i run ads how do i do
direct mail
how do i do how do i make posts how do i
make content how do i make like all of
those things are have to have to
encapsulate it in the book
which i think i've done an okay job
chunking up but the issue is i wanted it
to also be for me if you followed any of
my stuff there's two two things ideally
three but two that are requirements is
that it must be valid and it must be
useful
valid means that it's correct in a large
number of scenarios ideally in all
scenarios that means it has a high
degree of validity
useful means that if i actually do this
thing i will get the desired end goal
even if the y is not true but if i do
these things i get the angle and so i'll
give an example above so something that
is valid but not useful would be if i
said something's work and some things
don't that is 100 valid it's also not
useful at all right and on the flip side
so many
so many
sales marketing etc gurus for example
say like there are seven stages of
awareness and this is how someone walks
through a lead to become a customer and
they start
retroactively putting in thoughts into a
prospect's mind when we have no date no
way to validate that now if we do the
actions that they say in order to sell
stuff it might totally work but it
doesn't mean it's valid because i might
buy something not for those reasons and
so the idea is i need to be both valid i
need to be useful and the third bonus
for me is that it's entertaining because
if it's valid and useful then that will
make people money and many
self-motivated people will just go
through it for those things because they
know that this is a cheat code to making
money but if i get it to be entertaining
then i get more people to consume and
ultimately win so for the book right now
it is valid but the utility is lower
outside of just baseline understanding
how to
[Music]
market conceptually and so that has been
the issue that i'm having because i'm
trying to figure out whether i need to
like write you know eight sub books
which is a lot of work obviously um and
just have one book that explains
conceptually how this works so i'll give
you i'll give you some stuff that like
this might be interesting for you guys
that i had to unpack
what's the difference between promotion
marketing and advertising
right what is a lead
what's a lead if i get a subscriber on
youtube is that a lead
if i get a follower on instagram is that
a lead
what what makes it a lead what makes it
not a lead
i'll tell you the definition that i have
the book which is
information that you can leverage to
create a transaction that is a lead so
if i get a subscriber on youtube that is
not a lead if i get a follower on
instagram that is a lead
right because i can leverage that
conversation create a transaction they
might say well the follower on youtube
would maybe buy something yes but after
something else happens right if they
commented and i said hey give me your
number now i have the information
leverage to create a transaction right
and so um i've been i've been trying to
peel these layers back to create
with absolute clarity
something that people who want to get
more customers and the procedure of that
is getting more lead flow or deal flow
if i that they could read the book and
immediately execute everything in the
book and increase their lead flow and so
that has been the trouble that i've had
in trying to encapsulate that simply in
a simple book while also accounting for
all of the disparate ways that you can
generate leads through attention and so
the second big breakthrough that i had
was something that i called the
advertising cycle which
you'll have to read the book um but
basically i made 58 broken models to get
this to work the way i needed it to and
i would consider this the value equation
of this book and so
um
i am working on it it just because we're
also running acquisition.com
um and actually like growing the
business why not like writing the book
um takes time and i just won't put out
a product that i don't think is
deserving of your attention and so
i will always hold that as the hard line
and so i promise that when it is done it
will be worthy of it to the best of my
human ability
so um with that being said i hope you
guys enjoyed the first live ever q a of
uh solo if you guys uh
can give a caleb a shout out because
this was all his idea and if no one's
there i will blame him and i will have
won the bet that i've been talking to
myself for this entire time
um
but anyways uh mozation i love you guys
uh if you for some reason are new on
here um we have a book that's 99 cents
that a lot of people are referencing
anything that's 5 000 five-star reviews
on amazon it's 99 cents if you want to
check it out a lot of people get value
from it um the the podcast uh is you're
a podcast listener we have a podcast
that encapsulates a lot of this stuff at
higher level i don't sell anything like
the whole reason acquisition.com is this
is because i'm trying to help businesses
that are doing three million or more and
so if you are a business that's doing
three million or more and you're on the
internet love to work with you hop on
acquisition.com fill out the fill out
the form we'd love to help you get to 30
million and beyond um we've done it six
times already so we're pretty good at it
especially for this type of business
but if you're below three million and
you're not in that industry or you're
through you're below three million and
you're in that industry that's why we
make the book we make youtube we make
twitter content we make uh instagram
content and we just i'm just trying to
give everybody the tools they need to uh
that i wish i had had um earlier on not
saying they're right i'm just saying
they've worked for me so anyways
appreciate your emoji nation you guys i
don't deserve you but i am grateful for
you nonetheless so thank you guys i'll
see you guys the next instagram live